having already discussed two of the four
Titan brothers who are personified as
the pillars of the earth today we take a
look at the last two crius ne Appetit
starting with crius who's almost
certainly the least mentioned of the
titan brothers who played a role in
Uranus's castration crius was seen as a
southern pillar his name can be
translated to mean ram an animal that
was seen to symbolize the start of
spring in the greek year as the
constellation aries was in the shape of
a ram and was the first constellation
visible in the sky during the season of
spring there is some debate as to what
crius was actually the god of his
association with the greek zodiac has
led many to believe that he was a god of
constellations and he symbols that of a
ram he was married to Arabia a daughter
of Pontus and Gaia and one of the
earliest deities to be associated of the
sea together they had three children
estrellas the titan god of dusk who
would eventually marry a oz the goddess
of dawn alas the titan god of warcraft
whose children are thought to symbolize
victory rivalry strength and power and
lastly Percy's the titan god of
destruction
who would marry the goddess Asteria and
father hikari there are no real mentions
of crius in the myths and stories of
greek mythology so we can assume that he
must have been amongst the Titans
imprisoned in Tartarus after the war and
like so many of the elder Titans their
significance was mostly in sire in the
next generation a generation of gods who
would go on to play a larger role and
all those that preceded them the loss of
the four brothers left for us to discuss
izya pitous the pillar of the west and
the titan god of the mortal lifespan the
appetizers names thought to mean pierce
and he was often referred to as the
piercer a name that scholars have
debated the meaning of for years there
are those who associate the term pierce
with the spear believing that the
Apatosaurus man God the opposing
argument is that hepatitis was the goal
of the mortal lifespan which also makes
him a god of death
the term pierce in this instance would
refer to the violent death caused on the
wounds of a spear when he happened to
salute the ones time had passed
he brought a violent death upon them
the appetizer at the oceanic lemony and
together they had four children
prometheus Epimetheus mini OTS and Atlas
their children would go on to feature in
quite a few of the myths and stories of
Greek mythology and become extremely
recognizable figures with the exception
of many OTS who in many accounts was
killed by Zeus during the war when the
two encountered each other on not
truthfully when Cronus defeated his
father he a / - stood by his brother's
side and was considered quite an
important figure because he was believed
equal to Cronus in terms of power it's
mentioned by both known as the Greek
poet and the Roman poet Gaius valerius
flaccus and at some point in the war the
a pitous fort Zeus in a fierce battle
and after defeating the Titan Zeus then
became the rule of the cosmos as there
was no one left to oppose him there's no
doubt that the appetizer was an
extremely powerful Titan even being
compared to Cronus in terms of overall
status and ability his confrontation
with Zeus during the war is one of the
very few documented events that we have
that involved the Titans
but even so much like crius and the
other elder tightens the epitarsis
somewhat overshadowed by the actions and
achievements of his children having now
heard the stories of the four brothers
that represent the four pillars of the
earth out of coiours crius Hyperion and
the Apatosaurus
are there any that you dislike are there
any that you feel you associated with
more than others let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained